you will move in the direction of the
people that you associate with
we're looking for evidence of
exceptional ability uh and it really
doesn't matter if you're wanting to
graduate high school or college or
anything there's no reason people help
you
you get a help because you earn the
credit you earn the repetition
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
i believe a hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know you've got
something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level of
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and learn how
billionaires think
and get some success advice from the top
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one choose who you
associate with with warren buffett you
will
move in the direction of the people that
you associate with so i
it's important to associate with people
that are better than yourself and
actually the most important decision
many of you make not all of you will be
the spouse you're choosing
and uh you really
you want to associate with people who
are the kind of person you'd like to be
you'll you'll move in that direction and
the most important person by far
in that respect is your spouse i can't
overemphasize how important that is and
you're right
the friends you have uh they will form
you as you go
through life and uh
make some good friends keep them for the
rest of your life but
have them be people that you admire as
well as like them
rule number two have exceptional ability
with elon musk
what do you look for in the people you
hire especially the engineers
i really just look for evidence of
exceptional ability
so it's not at least aspirationally like
sometimes these things get
messed up in recruiting or the
recruiting photo beings
it ends up being wrong like i sometimes
wonder with tesla
if nikola tesla applied to tesla would
we even give him an interview
it's not clear you know this guy came
from like some weird college and
somewhere in eastern europe i think he's
got some odd mannerisms
now we don't know if we should give an
interview like i i worry that that's
actually what we do instead of like
it should be like man [ __ ] this this
this
kid's super smart what does he want
we'll pay him anything
that should that should be the reaction
if nikola tesla applies you know
to tesla um ironically uh but
so i can tell you the intent is we're
looking for evidence of exceptional
ability
uh and it really doesn't matter if
you're wanting to graduate high school
or
college or anything we're just looking
for evidence of exceptional ability
uh such that it would be a good
predictor for doing exceptional things
spacex
rule number three have fun with jeff
bezos
one of the first times that i read that
i demoed recommendations
live um with a live uh website
i um uh was speaking to a
group of uh of uh wall street analysts
and um and my number one recommendation
number one personal recommendation was
the dvd
called slave girls beyond infinity
and which was this is much less
embarrassing and you never know what
you're going to get i never know exactly
what i'm going to get because it is live
and it does change you know from
minute to minute but i'm glad to see
that today i've gotten
you know apollo um
uh and then i can see of course why was
i recommended this
because i bought cosmos and angle of
attack
and another book called apollo um so
but slave grows beyond infinity i'll
just show you was
was a little embarrassing
[Laughter]
um what happened to that laser pointer
thing oh here it is
do not look directly into me okay um
there it is slave girls from beyond
infinity let's go over here
uh this is pretty interesting um it's
uh so you can buy this dvd with a salt
of the killer bimbos
buy together it's only 1996.
all of that product clustering is done
automatically of course
the um you come down and you'll notice
that you know customers who bought
slave girls also bought
sorority babes in the slime ball bolo
rama and my personal favorite
cannibal women in the avocado jungle of
death
and there's this interesting thing here
we um we even
know when things are part of a series so
we say and also they bought dvds from
the barbarian queen
series so we can click through quick
click through and look at the barbarian
queen and
there's a customer review here it says
for lena clarkson fans only this is
barbarian queen
2. this is not even barbarian queen it's
an incredibly bad film whose only
redeeming feature is laina clarkson
in and out of some skimpy outfits she's
completely gorgeous but even she can't
save a disaster of a film
then here comes the great recommendation
buy death stalker instead
[Laughter]
lesson number four don't be dependent on
one vertical
with grant cardone i mentioned that
whilst writing 10x raw
something changed for you yeah yeah what
was that
was it was that sort of this look the
10x rule to going all
in or no the 10x world was it was just
the awareness of
i had been dependent upon one vertical
right
and i'm sitting there looking okay i
work my ass off
uh i i was good at my craft i saved my
money
what did i do wrong here dude 51 years
old
i should have i should be like so rich
right now
i got i mean i should be like not even
huh where's my jet racing i wouldn't
even think about it
right i wasn't even thinking about jet i
should just be like
i was still having to do business with
people i didn't like i'm like why am i
still kissing asses
and i don't mind kissing asses like i
don't mind i'll do whatever it takes but
i'm like why am i still flying three
million miles
every three years like i was banging
miles down i went
150 000 miles a year wow you know
away from my family like like my life
was miserable i'm like
it's fine that you do that for 20 years
it's not fine if you do it forever
and i'm like oh my god dude i wasn't
scaling
now i didn't know that until the economy
um basically served up the lesson right
all right we're going to take your three
businesses
and we're going to show you that we you
really only have like
maybe a half of one business
took took the first business and just
cut it in half took the second business
took it down to like 90 like just killed
this partner i had
and the third business was real estate
and it was frozen it was literally like
they put it in a freezer and said you
can't
you're not gonna lose any of this but
it's worth nothing to you today yeah
and i was a life support and i'm like
i'll never do this again i will never be
dependent upon one vertical
one partner or a handful of real estate
hey man everybody how you doing buddy
good how are you you got a book coming
out don't you
uh you just came out where can people
get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve
right there let's go man if you guys
don't know evan follow evan carmichael
he's got a new book out build a serve go
grab it today at amazon
there's a good dude right here rule
number five find
good friends with oprah winfrey you wish
yourself
they call her auntie gayle and me mamo i
said you all wish to have a friend like
auntie gayle
you want to have a friend who wants
the most the best and the highest for
you
i have never seen a person like gayle
i've never
yeah you know everybody especially if
you
uh are on the rise in your career and
you have had certain friends
and they all act like they're happy for
you but not everybody's happy for you
and every now and then you can hear just
a teen 90 bit of jealousy you can hear
it you can
sense it i've never had a moment's
jealousy from gail
in you know the 30 odd years of her
friendship except
for the one time i was on stage dancing
with tina turner
that's the only time i ever heard gail
goes i wish that was me
rule number six build your reputation
with jack ma
a lot of startups complain that they
never get the money from banks
never get money from the other venture
capitalists
well rejected by banks
rejected by your venture capital is very
normal
you got money from these guys not normal
why people want to help you
right there's no reason people help you
you get help because you earn the
credit you earn the repetition
so borrow money from your friends
families that's the sec first step
that's everybody
if you cannot even borrow money from
your friends and relatives you guys have
a problem
nobody trusts you right so i heard you
bottle through
two thousand one thousand dollars that's
good
that that means you have
this trust from those people
that around you at least you got
somebody and rule number seven the last
one before some very special bonus clips
is always be open to learning with peter
thiel
assembling a crew of people who are very
smart
very fast learners was kind of the key
to a success in a startup
as opposed to trying to get someone who
had you know if they had 10 years
experience doing something that's great
but the more fundamental characteristic
is would they learn
fast on the new problems and the new
challenges yeah it's it always feels
wrong to be
anti-experience but the uh the place
where it can backfires if the experience
makes you think that you know everything
yes and so it's again it's important to
know things and it's important
to be open to learning more and in
theory
experience is a plus in practice it's
often uh
often a bit of a minus because people
are less open to learning new things
or they're more set on doing a
particular job in the context of a
startup which is always very tricky
where you have small numbers of people
and people need to be very flexible
about the roles and the roles change as
the company gets built now i've got some
special bonus clips that i think you're
going to enjoy but before that
it's time for the question of the day i
want to know what was your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week
when you just watch a video and you get
motivated the sign says you have a 35
chance of actually following through
that's not good enough believe nation
we need to take some action but when you
watch a video you get motivated and you
create a specific
plan of action that number jumps from 35
to 91 chance of you following through
and when you publicly commit to other
people like leaving a comment down in
this video
your number jumps to 95 chains of you
actually following through on the plan
you set for yourself
so i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week leave it down in the comments below
so i can celebrate you what are you most
grateful for in your life recently
my children that's easy yeah my four
children
i think every mom has to say that right
or it's just i mean it's true it's
really how i feel
um i'm also really grateful for being a
woman
born in the right country at the right
time i had nothing to do with that and
i'm
very grateful and i wake up all the time
thinking of that
you know my mom we're only 21 difference
in
age 21 years my mom her
choices were so much more limited and
what was expected of her or what her
opportunities were
so i mean if you think about how long
we've been on the planet some people
think a couple thousand years some
people think a couple million
anyway it's a long time and by just 20
years
in the right country i feel like
i was born and had the opportunity for
spanx yeah
you know to fulfill a potential or
something inside of me as a woman that
was in me and so i'm grateful for that
this is how we keep our innovation
running
i think usually as companies get bigger
they find it really hard to have
small innovative projects and we had
this problem too for a while and we said
oh
we really need a new concept you know
the google ads that's a small project
that we're not quite sure if it's going
to work or not
but we hope it will and if we do enough
of them
some of them will really work and turn
out such as news but then we had a
we had a problem because then we had
over 100 projects
and i don't know about all of you but i
have trouble keeping a hundred things in
my head at once
and we found that if we just wrote all
of them down
uh and ordered them and these are kind
of made up
don't really pay attention to them for
example the the by iceland was
from a media article we would never do
such a crazy thing but
in any case um we found if we just
basically wrote them all down and
ordered them
that uh most people would actually agree
what the ordering should be
and this was kind of a surprise to me
but we found that as long as you keep
the 100 things in your head
which you did by writing them down that
you could do a pretty good job deciding
what to do
and where to put your resources i always
kind of like
i get a little upset whenever any media
attention
focuses on me personally and me leaving
facebook
much less a movie it's been it's been
kind of a bad year
hasn't it it turned out okay time
academy
it turned out it turned it turned out
great the time thing was awesome um
the um those really flattering but like
but i think that it's one of these
things that the media systematically
gets
wrong is that this idea that it's a
person right it's never a person
right it's always a team and the most
important thing if you
are an entrepreneur trying to build
something is you need to build a really
good team and that's what i spend a lot
of my time on right i mean i spend
um probably at least three hours a day
with our core team
right at doing things i spend probably
25 percent of my time recruiting finding
good people
both outside the company and inside the
company to put in more
and more impactful roles i think the
media
there's a little bit of this cultural
bias towards thinking that
you know one person does this right i
mean people say that you know i built
facebook or steve jobs built apple or
whatever but
you know that's really not true right i
mean it's we're
we're people we we helped uh but there
were thousands and thousands of other
people involved in building these things
and the reality is is that as strong as
any one individual is
no one person can deal with all the
challenges that are going to get thrown
at them
in anything that you do and one of the
ways that i think we maintain resilience
is by having co-founders and partners
who complement our strengths and
fortify our weaknesses and can kind of
encourage us
and give us a push to to keep going when
things are tough
and there's actually a lot of data on
this that suggests that
companies that get started with more
co-founders
are more likely to be successful and it
isn't quite clear
um exactly from that data why that's the
case although it is very clear
in terms of the outcome for the startups
that it is the case um
but i would guess that the reason why
that's the case
is because of this resilience point
where people who start something by
themselves
i just think like there's no way that
any one person
can overcome all of the different things
that you need to do to
to build a startup or take on any kind
of other project in the world
but if you have two or three or four
partners then
i don't know i mean maybe over time one
of them
doesn't like it and drops out but you
still have enough strength on the team
to
power through all the challenges that
you have and that's kind of how you go
and
you know at facebook today one of the
things that i always find a little bit
funny is again that so much attention is
placed on on me as the person running
the company
whereas i think you know people like
cheryl who
really you know is my partner running
the whole business or you know folks
like chris cox who run
a huge amount of our product or uh mike
schrepfer who's our
chief technology officer and and kind of
make sure that a ton of
uh what we're doing works or jay parikh
who you know runs all of our global
infrastructure and
in all the data centers around the world
we couldn't make facebook work without
those people
right and and there were really hard
days where where i'm not sure what to do
next and
and they keep me going so 198 1979
80 81 i calculated that american banks
had lent a lot more money to
emerging countries than those countries
are going to get paid back
and i anticipate that there would be a
debt crisis
and with that an economic crisis so that
was my
thinking in august 1982
mexico defaulted on its debt and a
number of countries
followed and so because i said that
i got a lot of attention about that and
i thought that was going to be producing
a bear market in stocks and i could not
have been
more wrong august 1982 was the exact
bottom of the stock market
and i was wrong and as a result of that
um let's take my employees or
um i had to let them go i lost money for
myself
i lost money for and i had to borrow
four thousand dollars for my dad
it was the most painful one of the most
painful experiences but it was one of
the best
experiences that ever happened to me in
my life because
it it changed my perspective about
decision making
it made um it made gave me the humility
that i needed and what i did
every time i made a mistake they became
painful mistakes but with time i
realized that reflecting on those
mistakes would give me gems
what i would do is i'd say why did i
make that mistake
and i would learn from that mistake and
i'd write down a rule
so what was helpful for me is i put that
rule
principles these principles i wrote
these principles down
those principles that i wrote down i
then put into algorithms in other words
equations and what i learned by being
able to do that
is by if i took my decision criteria
those principles
and then i tested them back through time
i gained a perspective that was
fantastic
i could test them in back a hundred
years
i could test them in different countries
and i would learn how those rules work
and i put by putting all those rules
together and then how
having these algorithms the computer can
replicate my thinking but it could
actually think better than i could
because it what it would do
is it would take it could process more
information
it could process it faster and it could
process it less emotionally
mistakes are how we learn because
mistakes produce pain
and if you produce that and you convert
that to learning
like for example punishing people for
mistakes
is bad because they hide things where if
you were to say to your kid and
who makes a mistake the only thing you
have to do is tell me what would you
have done different in the future
and then will be good that learns makes
that a learning process or weaknesses
everybody has weaknesses has number of
weaknesses the great people that i've
seen
um in almost any area always have
weaknesses
they just have known what their
weaknesses are are
and have ways of getting around those
weaknesses we've probably spent less
money in marketing than any
company our size in the world we have a
tiny marketing department
and everyone says why oracle's you know
all about sales and marketing
we are the largest employer of mit and
caltech engineers in the world
we are the largest employer of stanford
and
harvard and cmu mathematicians in the
world
we are overwhelmingly dominated by
engineering
at oracle the idea that we are a sales
and marketing company which people
will sometimes will write about quite
often is
ludicrous on the face of it because
all of our customers who buy oracle
already have it
and if you already have oracle there's
nothing a salesman can tell you about
how great it is to make you buy more
ge already uses it the defense
department always you already use it
all of our customers 98 of our sales or
more
are to existing oracle customers
if we don't have the right product
people don't buy more
we will before the acquisition we spend
three billion dollars a year in software
engineering
the company is all about engineering
it's the only thing that works how would
you describe
each phase of the evolution of oracle
and how would you
uh sort of describe running each of
those phases
you got to do this quick i gotta well
i mean and clearly being a part of a
company with four people and being a
part of a company and by the way that's
we're 85 000 now post
post merger with sun you know uh on 100
uh we think about
sun's got about 20 000 employees and you
know uh 25 000 employees we're about 105
000.
uh so uh hundred five hundred ten
thousand we're not sure exactly
about that uh i mean clearly my job is
constantly changed uh
what has not changed is i ran
engineering at oracle on the first day
i run engineering today the one part of
the company i have always paid attention
to
and is always reported directly to me is
engineering not sales
not marketing not support and not
consulting not services
at various points in time lots of other
people have run run those operations the
back office
accounting order management all of these
things the only thing
that i've done consistently during those
32 years is run engineering
because i believe basically that once
you reach
you will you know you'll win as as as we
say at oracle
it's amazing our good products seem to
do very well and our bad products
not so well so the thing i focused on
and i think we get the most
most leverage is developing the right
products recruiting the right engineers
and having the right organization
i learned a lot from our founders and
one of the things i learned was
ask the impossible and really dream big
what you learn about
people is if you paint a very broad
vision you attract people who really
want to make it happen
because they're dreamers too so you can
inspire people and with that inspiration
you get
the smartest people and they deal with a
lot of stuff but can
an organization like google which
espouses the idea that you're going to
give
people in the organization 15 or 20 of
their time to do
almost anything they want in terms of
innovation can that system work
in smaller companies can that system
work in any company is that a leadership
tenant that can work across a broad
range of companies
well in fact it worked at google when
google was tiny so the answer is yes it
does work in small companies
remember we give this to engineers and
engineers are not that clever
right if they're going to work on
something in their 20 time
it's going to be something that's pretty
related
to their training and their knowledge
and that's why it's so powerful
very very few people sort of get off the
reservation and do something completely
different from
technology and so forth and if they did
we would encourage it has something
manifest that you can recall come from
just that kind of incubation
virtually all of the interesting apps
now came from a combination of
an acquisition and a 20 time if you look
at maps if you look at google earth if
you look at
chrome and android all of them came from
somebody trying something identifying
something and then we would say
we have all these 20 timers but we need
a real group
and the fastest way to do that was to
create a real group or buy a company
larry and sergey almost got acquired
can you tell us a little bit about this
and i always wonder what the world
how the world might be different if that
had in fact
happened
uh well uh we had developed this
technology we called uh
page rank sadly not rin rank but anyway
you probably would have sold better that
way but um
uh we developed this technology that we
found was useful for search
it by itself uh it wasn't really a
complete search engine what we had
kind of just searched titles of web
pages and
and ranked them quite well
but we showed it to a bunch of the
existing search companies back then
some of you might remember them you know
infoseek excite
lycos and
probably the greatest interest came from
excite and actually came from the node
you were
the the investor in excite and we spent
a while
uh talking to them and talking talking
to you the node
yeah you remember that in the end
i don't think the management team there
was quite as excited
about it no pun intended um
but i remember we were you know we were
just there were four
of us at the time four grad students at
stanford
and i remember we fired off a note to
the node it was just like a little email
we said like you know we don't really
want to sell
but okay for 1.6 million dollars you got
a deal and
uh a few minutes later we got a reply
and said that's a lot of dough but okay
we'll do it
um
i know that's characteristic the note
right so then
ten minutes later scott one of the four
of us comes running in
laughing huge grin on his face he had
faked the reply
and uh
yeah back then you know the ethics
around faking you
weren't quite the same anyway um
so he had that big joke and the deal
obviously never came to fruition and
we went our own way to build
build search education is essentially a
social construct
it's not that the universities have
secret knowledge that only they
have available uh you know i took
these numbers won't make any sense
anymore but the hardest freshman math
class was called math 55
uh i assume it's not called that anymore
but it was it was a group of
uh as a group of 80 people whose
personal positioning was they were the
best person at math
that they had ever met so there were 79
frauds
uh one person who really was the
the best at math i ended up the guy who
came in first in the class is a lawyer
in new york now
uh the guy who came in second as a
professor of chaos theory of
uh princeton uh and then i came in third
so i knew okay math geez that's
interesting
anyway uh
i didn't take physics uh 55
but i read the feynman book and so if
you're motivated
seriously you don't have to take a
course the feynman book if you're
hardcore
just read the finding book do the
problems you want to learn
to do software read the art of computer
programming good luck doing the problems
but
uh you know anyone that's rated 30 or
harder is like
super hard to do and so
a mooc in a sense doesn't change what
counts
uh you know it's always been in the
textbook but the percentage of students
who just buy textbooks and
and read them and know the subject is
vanishingly small
you kind of have to have this thing
where a bunch of kids all come at the
same time
uh and you know if you don't study
you're going to get a bad grade
and your parents may not like that you
have to create all these social
things in order for people to get into
this mode of
hyper concentrating and actually
understanding
why should i concentrate you know if i'm
a high school student they put
x's and y's up on the board how does
that relate to my life
now if you understood that being good at
math lets you get a good job travel the
world
you might say okay it does relate to me
but that's a very
indirect thing and the kind of
discipline
to care about that uh to concentrate
that's what's missing and so moocs to
the degree that it's easier to take a
mooc than it is to read a textbook yeah
that's nice it's a little bit
interactive there's a video
that's probably why i like the learning
company like all their economics there's
a guy named timothy taylor who has
five courses on economics i super
recommend uh
and you learn to like him and his way of
explaining things so a mooc is a
slightly more digestible form
of learning but it doesn't take
particularly for somebody at a young age
it in no way changes this question of
why should people
engage in that learning and how do you
create the environment
and the sense of achievement and the
sense of capability
that sitting in there and you know
looking at x's and y's and manipulating
them
seems like a smart thing to do what are
the things you think about that make
companies successful
in this type of environment versus those
that struggle
well i think it starts with us having
a long-term view rather than a
short-term view
and always thinking of how we can be
successful
long term by creating value with for
others
starting with our customers and
employees
and so when we look at it that way
there's always uncertainty
so it starts with being prepared with
that and
and recognizing that the future
is unknown and unknowable so the way we
have
prepared ourselves for that is focusing
on building capabilities that will be
make us successful under a whole variety
of conditions which means
having more flexibility more optionality
more diversity and so those are the
things that
we've always tried to do and so the
starting point
is is building capabilities that will
enable us to create value with others
starting with our customers
and then finding the opportunities
or the sets of customers for whom we can
create the most value
and then as we do not resting on our
laws but
recognizing the future is going to be
different than the past
then continually improving and adding to
those capabilities
and as we do then we see oh with those
capabilities
we can now pursue additional
opportunities
and then as we start pursuing those
opportunities we realize well we need
additional capabilities so we add still
more capabilities
so this creates what i've called a
virtuous cycle of mutual benefit
where it's continual improvement
and growth and and diversity which is
is a way in or or is
the way to deal with schumpeter's
what he called creative destruction my
dad
did upholstery on cars so if you got a
rip in your car seat
you would take it to where he worked um
my mom did work odd jobs from wherever
and we you know we had we lived in a
okay
neighborhood but we weren't poor by a
long shot but we were truly middle class
and i over and over my dad didn't go to
college my mom didn't go to college
and so they would beat him to me you're
going to college
and they used to make me work at odd
jobs
so that i would learn the value of work
and and
you know one i'd go where my dad worked
doing it with cars
and he'd make me sweep the whole and
this place was nasty
make me sweep all the time you know
tried to get me a job in the middle but
couldn't give me a job in the mill
my mom wanted me to lay carpet because
she was worried about me
if i didn't have a trade and so she got
a
friend of hers to try to get me to teach
me how to lay carpet
and if you ever go there's this little
office in pittsburgh pennsylvania if you
trip over the carpet
that's where i learned how to lay carpet
um
and i was going through these things i'm
like this is just not me and and i
always had that
that individual spirit to say okay you
know
i can come up with things that can make
me money
i mean when i was nine i would sell
baseball cards when i was 12
um i told my dad i wanted a pair of
basketball shoes
and it just so happens he was playing
poker with his buddies who were all
probably drip roaring drunk at the time
and i
just didn't realize it but i was like
dad i want a new pair of tennis shoes
you know the
the new beta bullets were coming out or
whatever they were
and um new converse and he's like you
see those shoes on your feet
they work just fine when you have a job
you can go buy whatever you want i'm
like dad i'm 12. i don't have a job
and one of his buddies stood up with
duster up but he said hey i got
i got a job for you he had these boxes
of garbage bags
and he's like i've got these boxes of
garbage bags i don't know what to do
with why don't you sell them
i'm like cool you know what do they cost
me and
they literally were a box of 100
these blue garbage bags that he would
sell them to me
for three bucks and then i would i went
door to door
i was like hi
my name is mark do you use garbage bags
and i learned i could sell it's just
like okay six bucks you know i'll drop
them off whenever you need them just
call me and i made some money bought my
shoes and
you know and that just gave me
confidence and it took off from there
if you can remember back to you know
when you were kind of my age
did you think you would have all of this
oh yeah absolutely
no um i had no idea i grew up in
pittsburgh
um my dad did upholstery on cars if you
got a rip in your car seat you took it
to him
my mom had odd jobs from selling
real estate to making baskets and you
know
i was just a normal kid but i i was
always into business
from as long as i could remember i was
selling something or
or working on something trying to make
money um
and i just it just got me excited to to
be a business person and it just took
off from there you know you always have
to think ahead you know in business
sometimes what is good today might not
be
good tomorrow so you need to you know
look at it if you have the means
there's nothing really like
diversification
you know sometimes you do quite a lot of
diversification i mean diversification
and then
you consolidate before you move forward
you cannot just keep expanding expansion
because
sometimes when you over expand it can
cause a lot of
crisis also so you need at least
once in a while to consolidate and you
know
over one of the great secrets in life
to becoming successful whether it's in a
business
whether it's working with someone or for
someone or in your personal life
and i learned to sell an encyclopedia's
door-to-door early 20s
is be prepared in life for a lot of
rejection
because if you're prepared for a lot of
rejection it comes you don't get turned
off you don't get disappointed like well
i'm not going to do this anymore no one
thinks it's a good idea
it's like i say selling encyclopedias
knocking a hundred dollars
them in your face you must be just as
enthusiastic
on door number 101 as door number one
the best advice i could give
is number one be prepared for a lot of
rejection
if you're ready for rejection of people
say no i don't want it no it's not going
to work no this is crazy whatever
if you're prepared for it it's not going
to let you down
learn from your failures i had a lot of
failures along the way
even with my patron and paul mitchell
but we learn from those things then we
get a lot better
we got this new thing called classism
it's racism's cousin this is what we do
to hold people back
this is what we do and we got this other
thing that's also been working for a
long time where you don't have to be
racist anymore
it's called self-hate it works on itself
it's like real estate of racism
where just like that when someone comes
up and says something like i am a god
everybody says who does he think he is i
just told you who i thought i was a god
i just told you that's who i think i am
would it be better if i had a song that
said i am a [ __ ]
or if i had a song to say i'm a gangster
or if i had a song to say i am a pimp
all those colors and patinas fit better
on a person like me right but to say you
are a god
especially when you got shipped over to
the country that you're in
and your last name is a slave owners
how could you say that how could you
have that mentality
i mean i know in the past you've talked
about like you know
building hotels doing things that are
beyond people's normal frame of
reference
they know you as kanye western artists
they know that you that you're moving
into fashion but these
things i guess in a way are hard for
people to comprehend because they don't
have that level of
drive do you know what i mean has it
always been like this for you have you
always felt like
you can set your mind to anything and
you will achieve it ultimately
i always felt like i could do anything
[Applause]
that's the main thing people are
controlled by thoughts their perception
of themselves
they're slowed down by their perception
of themselves if you're taught you can't
do anything you won't do anything
i was taught i could do everything and
i'm kanye west at age 36.
so just watch the next 10 years for too
many of us myself included
we don't play enough we don't have
enough fun we don't
we don't take the risk that's in our
head and one of the things that i'm
constantly trying to work on is that
idea to action
right that when i come up with an idea
i'm going to do something about it and
it's especially hard when other people
are involved
it's especially hard in an interview
i'm sitting there talking to matthew
asking him about his career we spent an
hour together and we'll link up the
video at the end of this video
and as ideas come to me
[Music]
you constantly judge the question like
oh i don't know should i ask that
question
should i ask that question now is he
gonna is is that a good question is it
gonna be offended by the question
should i keep pulling on this thread is
that a good question now so should i
move on to the next topic it's this
constant kind of
track going on the back of my head and
what i've learned to do more and more
and more and more is just
trust the question
it came to you for a reason it may not
make sense
but trust the question if the intention
is good
right the intention isn't to make him
look bad or anybody else look bad right
the intention is good detention is
positive
this question came to me for a reason
trust it
do something on it i think that's one of
the biggest things that holds people
back is you get these ideas
in the moment like what if i did this
and you don't trust it
and then it it maybe disappears or maybe
you look back and say i wish i did that
this is why i started my first business
i actually didn't think it was going to
work out when i was 19 i had to choose
between
making 300 bucks a month and owning 30
in this company or
making six figures at my what i thought
was my dream job banking and traveling
around the world
i didn't think or no i wasn't like yes
this business is for sure going to work
out
this business for sure going to be my
big exit i'm going to make tons of money
it was more i didn't want to regret not
knowing that even if the most likely
scenario was failure
i still had to know
and i would rather no one fail than not
know
and what i've learned to do over the
past 20 years i guess and
still continue you know i still when i
get a question in my head or an idea in
my head
there's still a moment of hesitation and
that's what i'm constantly working on
getting rid of that idea to action
immediate
faster faster faster faster that this
idea came to me for a reason
that i have to at least try that i have
to at least take the first two percent
the two percent difference right stop
planning for 100
and just take action on the first two
percent that have to try
that i have to at least get a taste of
it
instead of prejudging it instead of
telling myself that it's not going to
work out
that as long as the intention is good
and the intention is to serve
and to help then i need to try
you can always back up from it
right like if i asked a question that
offended him i could always explain
where it came from i can always explain
the intent the worst case scenario isn't
that bad
it's not that bad you can almost always
make it up to somebody
versus the upside of actually doing it
and it works at it
and what you find is if you continue to
listen to that intuition if you continue
to listen to your big ideas
if you continue to ask the questions
that you want to ask do the thing that
you want to do
you'll find a much happier life you'll
find a much more impactful life
a much more purposeful life and i think
that's the life you deserve
there's a reason why in my videos i say
you have michael jordan level talent i
believe it it's true you
you have michael jordan level talent at
something you are the best
the absolute best at something
in the world most people either one
don't believe it they don't believe that
they're world class at something or two
they found the thing that they could be
world-class at but they don't have
enough guts to chase it down they don't
believe in themselves enough
to chase him down here's the thing you
need to first explore
you need to explore you got to search
you got to say yes you got to try things
you don't know that
that tim hortons is your favorite coffee
cup until you've tried it right you
don't know that sushi is your favorite
food until you've tried it
sushi doesn't make sense right this is
how we think our logical brain
starts to analyze things and because it
doesn't make sense we don't try it
sushi doesn't make sense you're gonna
take raw fish
mix it with rice put seaweed around it
and then eat it that sounds nasty
right if you've never tried it before it
sounds nasty
but it's the best a lot of the things
that you might be great at
you are a judge and you are dismissing
because it doesn't make logical sense
you don't need to wrap your head around
it you need to wrap your heart around it
you have to feel it you have to say yes
and be willing to try it at least once
if you don't know what you're great at
you have to say yes and try things
and you pay attention to the feeling the
most important thing is you pay
attention to the feeling how does it
make you feel you might not be great at
it
i expect not to get results at the
beginning of anything especially if it's
a new skill you're learning right expect
a second the beginning you're gonna suck
it's okay it's normal but how does it
make you
feel does it energize you do you want to
come back and do it again people aren't
lazy they just don't have dreams that
inspire them they
default to thinking i'm a lazy person i
don't have ambitions i don't know what i
want to do in life i'm just
i'm just a loser no you just don't have
a dream
that makes you want to go off and do
something and until you figure that out
you're going to be in this
constant cycle of feeling like a loser
it's one of the most common questions
that i get asked on my ig streams i go
live every single day on instagram
at least right now while i'm on my tour
and every single day i get asked some
variation of
evan i'm lazy how do i get out of it
evan i'm procrastinating
how do i get out of it one you don't
call yourself a lazy person
there's no such thing as a lazy person
if you are procrastinating or you're
being lazy
but you are being lazy doesn't mean that
you are a lazy person
there's two reasons why you're doing it
there's two reasons why you are being
lazy
one you don't have a dream that's big
enough you don't have something that
inspires you you don't want to get out
of bed in the morning if i was an
accountant i would be a really lazy
accountant i would hate my life
not to knock accountants it's just not
for me if i was a video editor
i would be i would be lazy i would hate
my life i don't want to be a video
editor i don't want to be an accountant
actually there's most things in the
world that i don't want to be
and if you forced me to do that i would
be lazy that's 95
of america i think 95 of america wakes
up and drive to the job that they hate
and then they're lazy there but they
have dreams
they have ambitions you have michael
jordan level talent at something
you just have to find it and so if you
don't know what that thing is then it's
your duty to go off and explore
you test you try you see you say yes to
a lot of stuff like this is the most
important thing that you need to figure
out in your life if you don't know what
your dream is
you have to go off and try things just
like you won't get married until you go
on dates
you won't get married to an idea until
you go on dates until you try until you
say yes
and the acid test is did i like it do i
want to go back does this fill me up did
i enjoy the process of it can i see
myself doing this and having fun because
when you're having fun
doing the work that's when it will fill
you up
that's when you won't be lazy and there
has been times in all your lives where
you felt that
where you felt the joy the energy the
ambition the drive and so you need to
capture that and say yes
and find what it is that your big dream
you need to tie yourself respect to your
efforts
not your results where you get yourself
love from your self-respect your
self-confidence should not come
from winning it comes from trying
because if you tie yourself respect to
winning you'll only do things that you
know you're gonna win at and therefore
you play small for life
so i'm training the guy on my team who
i've promoted
and i'm putting him in a position that
is way beyond his skill set way beyond
what he thought he'd be doing
and it's a big push outside his comfort
zone he was a guy who was doing a bunch
of admin tasks for me
and now he's in charge of all of my
youtube analytics i want him to be my
data god
i want him to go through the thousands
of videos that i have on my channel
and make recommendations to say this
intro is too long
this intro is too short this thumbnail
sucks you know when you
talk evan things blow up or things suck
when you wear black people love it
anything go through all the data go
through all the analytics
and tell me where we need to make
improvements so zona called with him
yesterday
and had to have a serious talk with him
because he's looking for data that
supports his hypothesis
because he suggested on my channel my
main channel
that we go back to my original intros
where i say one sentence here one
sentence here and one sentence here and
then he's
robert smith and here's my take on his
top 10 rules of success
right that's what we did way back like
in the very first original
series of the top tens and we've evolved
so
he suggested take out the song take out
the intro take out
a whole bunch of stuff and use to those
three things and let's see if it works
so that's what i did like great good
idea the data supported it
backed it up let's go and try we haven't
tried it we won't know
so we tried it the first video came up
was the robert f smith top 10 rules for
success
on that new template and i'm looking at
the data in it and it sucked
you know my goal is to get seventy
percent audience retention at one minute
that's what
that's my goal across my channels 70 its
retention at one minute that means
thirty percent of people
max have left at the one minute mark
that's an insanely high goal
to reach almost nobody hits that
especially consistently
you might think oh seventy percent it's
easy it's insanely difficult in the
youtube world
so i looked at the numbers for this one
and
it was 52 or something something brutal
we haven't we don't really operate in
the 52
range so this one came in it was brutal
52
like having a heart attack oh it sucked
people hate this
and then i asked him hey how are we
doing on the new videos and he sent me
this report that says hey
well on our relative data is up you know
a relative
of data saying compared to all videos on
youtube this video is doing well in the
first minute
yeah but that's that's not actually the
real story because
all of our videos relative to regular
youtube if you're looking at any video
this video and even my first read all of
them
every video i make relative to a normal
average youtube video
were higher relative that's not what i'm
looking for we're going after 70
audience retention at one minute you
know this this is where we're focused
and behind all of it was he just didn't
want to feel like a failure
he didn't want to feel like he
recommended something to me and it
didn't work out
that he's trying to justify it by saying
well look this stat shows that it works
but it's not what we're after
this experiment so far has been an epic
failure and that's okay
what i need you to do is expect to suck
expect the ideas not to work
no know that coming in know that coming
in we're already operating really high
level
right if every experiment that we try
works
that means that we just sucked at the
beginning right
we sucked you're learning you're picking
this up
most of my new experiments don't work
i'm trying hundreds of new things all
the time and most of them won't work i
expect to suck
but it's okay because i tie myself worth
to the effort am i putting my max
effort out your experiment talking to
the guy your experiment was
a great test i backed it the data
suggested we do it
but it's not working and we'll give it a
month to see
and if it still doesn't work we're going
to move on and do something else
if you want even more advice on how
billionaires think check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there that's not really
how it works if you don't love it
don't expect others will either your
relationship with time
is such a key component of your life
because when you get caught in a routine
time goes so quickly